Mark: Hey, guys!
Mark: Welcome to the Drunk Dunk Challenge.
Mark: Now for this one, we have drunk goggles right here.
Mark: And we've set up a mini-obstacle course.
Mark: So here's what's gonna happen.
(Ryan burps)
Mark: We are gonna put on these
Mark: And then we're gonna go over there.
Mark: And we're gonna get spun five times by one of our "Teammates"
Mark: Then we're gonna have to run this course
Mark: Which I can't see very well because I have the goggles on.
Mark: And there will be a ball right here waiting for us
Mark: That we have to pick up and then throw
Mark: Into that target!
Mark: But here's where it gets tricky.
Mark: If we miss, we have to go all the way back to the beginning
Mark: And keep doing it over and over and over again until we get it in there
Mark: Or
Mark: Three minutes?
Mark: Three minutes is good?
Matthias: Sure.
J-Fred: Three minutes!
Mark: Sounds good?
Mark: Ok.
Bryan: Sounds good to me.
J-Fred: Sounds like a long time.
Matthias: Ten spins?
Mark: Ten?
Mark: Ten to start, five after.
Matthias: Okay, ready?
J-Fred: Sounds fair.
J-Fred: Alright. 3--
Matthias: Why are you--
Matthias: Why are you doing that?
Mark: I'm ready to spin.
Matthias: I know, but why are you crouching?
Mark: I don't know.
Matthias: Stand up.
Mark: I don't know, man!
Matthias: Okay, ready?
Mark: Okay, I'm ready.
J-Fred: 3, 2, 1, go!
Matthias: 1
J-Fred: Watch your feet.
Matthias: 2
Matthias: 3--Oh watch where your hands go! 4
Matthias: 5, 6
Matthias: Watch out--Stop it! Don't kiss me!
Matthias: 8! Whoa!
(Mark laughs)
Matthias: 9!
Matthias: 10! Alright, go!
Mark: Whoa!
(Mark groans)
Matthias: Whoa, you've got it, dude!
Matthias: Yes!
(Matthias laughs)
(Mark grunts)
J-Fred: Go back!
Matthias: Hey, wait!
J-Fred: Go back! You've gotta go back!
Matthias: I've got to spin him again?
Mark: I can spin myself.
J-Fred: Watch your feet on that. You're gonna stub your toes
Mark: 1, 2
Mark: 3, 4, 5!
Mark: Oh god.
(Mark grunts)
Mark: Damn it!
J-Fred: That's where you got it last time.
(Mark makes crying noises)
J-Fred: It's only been 50 seconds.
Mark: What the hell?
Mark: 2, 3, 4, 5.
J-Fred: He's gonna puke!
Mark: This is also called the "Mark Pukes Challenge"
Mark: (Gasping) Okay.
Mark: Okay.
(Mark grunts)
J-Fred: Whoa!
Mark: What happened? It looked like it was close!
J-Fred: You've got to go back!
Mark: Aww!
J-Fred: You've got a 1:45 left.
Mark: Oh jeez.
(Mark groaning)
Matthias: That's a workout!
J-Fred: Watch your--
All: Ooh!
Mark: I'm okay!
J-Fred: You're gonna break your ankle.
Mark: I'm okay.
Matthias: Whoa!
Mark: I'm okay! I'm okay!
Bryan: What's the obstacle course? I don't get it. It looks easy.
Mark: Shut up!
Mark: Oh no!!!
Matthias: You're never gonna hit that, bro.
J-Fred: He's gonna be so tired.
J-Fred: Okay, let's just say two minutes.
J-Fred: How about just two minutes?
J-Fred: You have 20 seconds left if you're going two minutes.
(Mark makes dizzy noises)
J-Fred: You're so screwed.
Mark: I got it!
Matthias: What in the world?
J-Fred: Take your time.
(Bryan screams)
Bryan: No!
(Mark grunts)
Matthias: It's so high!
(Mark shouts)
Mark: Damn it!
(Bryan laughs)
Bryan: Ow, my toes!
Mark: Damn it!
J-Fred: So...
Mark: Do I have time left?
J-Fred: Yeah, you've got a minute left.
Mark: Ah shit.
Bryan: I thought it was only two minutes.
Matthias: Two minutes.
Matthias: Two minutes is plenty.
J-Fred: So we're just gonna make it two minute so we don't throw up.
Mark: (Out of breath) Who's there?
Mark: Oh god.
Mark: Oh, sweet ground!
Mark: Oh my god.
J-Fred: Alright, you're on the dunk tank.
Mark: It's so hard!
Bryan: I'll go next?
Mark: You guys don't know!
Mark: It's so hard!
J-Fred: 3, 2, 1, Go!
Matthias: 1, 2.
J-Fred: Spin him away from the--
Matthias: 3
J-Fred: Don't let him--
Bryan: Whoa!
J-Fred: Don't hit the--
Mark: You've got nothing to mine!
Bryan: I thought you're supposed to be spinning me.
J-Fred: 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Bryan: What's the obstacle course?
J-Fred: 8
J-Fred: 10. You've got to go through these things like a dog.
(Laughter)
Matthias: No, no, no!
Matthias: You've got to start over.
J-Fred: Go back! Go back!
Matthias: You can't kick the cones, bro!
J-Fred: Do five more!
J-Fred: Go back!
J-Fred: Five spins.
Matthias: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Mark: Go for it! Go!
Matthias: Don't touch the cones, dude!
Matthias: No!
J-Fred: Hey, he touched it!
Bryan: Come on!
J-Fred: Go! Go! Go! Go! Go!
Matthias: Oh, now you hit it over!
Matthias: What the heck is he doing?
Mark: I'll give it to you.
Mark: Oh.
(Matthias laughs)
J-Fred: Okay, this is just a sorry display.
(Laughter)
Mark: Oh jeez.
Matthias: Wait, wait.
J-Fred: You've gotta go back!
Mark: Wow.
Bryan: Was that even close?
J-Fred: You can't throw it anymore.
Mark: No.
J-Fred: Go again.
J-Fred: Five spins.
Bryan: Ow, I just stubbed my toe!
J-Fred: 1, 2, 3, 4.
Mark: Is he good?
Matthias: Yeah.
Matthias: Bryan, spin.
J-Fred: 5. Go!
Bryan: Okay. I got this.
Bryan: I got this.
Mark: You're doing great. You're doing great, man.
Mark: Do it terribly. Do bad now.
Matthias: Oh! Okay, okay!
Bryan: How much time do I have left?
Mark: I don't know.
J-Fred: You have 30 seconds left.
Bryan: I'm gonna puke!
Bryan: 1
(Bryan groans)
Matthias: Dude, 8 more.
J-Fred: He's like so bad at that.
Matthias: I know, right?
Matthias: Every single one.
(Mark yelps)
(Mark yelps in slow motion)
(Mark laughs)
Bryan: 3, 2, 1, go!
Mark: I'm gonna keep you in a box.
J-Fred: 1, 2...
Mark: Lean this way.
Mark: 4
Mark: 5, 6
Mark: This way! Go this way!
Mark: Go this way! 7! 7!
Mark: 7! 7!
Mark: 8
Mark: 9! One more!
Mark: 10, and go!
Mark: Nope, not that way! Whoa!
Bryan: Look at those happy feet!
Mark: Happy feet!
Mark: Wow!
Bryan: Nope.
Mark: I got it. I got it.
J-Fred: 2!
J-Fred: 3, 4
J-Fred: 5!
Mark: Go! Go! Go, go, go!
Mark: Go, go, go, go!
Mark: Don't do football moves.
(Matthias screams)
(Matthias screams in slow motion)
(Matthias screaming and Mark laughing)
Matthias: What the heck??
(Mark laughing)
Matthias: Oh, it's cold!
(Water splashing)
Mark: Oh, man.
Bryan: Go!
Mark: Uno.
Mark: Dos. Tres.
J-Fred: Ooh, it's cold, baby!
Mark: 4
Mark: 9.
Mark: 11.
Mark: 21.
Mark: 42.
Mark: 9.
Bryan: Look at that spin.
Mark: 10!
Bryan: Go!
Mark: You're good.
Mark: Alright, go for it, man.
Bryan: How was I so bad?
Mark: I don't know! You were like--
Matthias: Oh!
Bryan: There it is.
(Mark laughing)
Matthias: Why can't I see anything?
Mark: You got it! You got it! You got it!
Mark, Matthias, Bryan: Whoa!
(Soft laughter)
Matthias: There is literally nothing to hold my balance.
Mark: Wow!
Mark and Bryan: Get back. You've gotta go back!
Bryan: I hit it. Ow, dude!
Bryan: You pushed me.
Matthias: I didn't mean to!
(Mark laughing)
Bryan: Too far! Too far!
Matthias: Ow!
(Laughter)
Matthias: Ah!
(More laughter. Matthias is clumsy.)
Bryan: Go.
Bryan: 5--
Matthias: What the heck?
Mark: 5 spins.
Bryan: You have one minute!
Bryan: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Bryan: 6?
Mark: He keeps wanting to do a bonus one. He's an overachiever.
Mark: We can all appreciate that.
Bryan: Okay.
Mark: That's the technique I was using.
(J-Fred shouts out in surprise)
Bryan: Whoa! Why are you holding on?
J-Fred: I didn't!
Bryan: Cheater!
J-Fred: I jumped out as soon as it happened, cuz I got scared.
J-Fred: Alright, alright.
J-Fred: Oof!
(Laughter)
Mark: Alright, guys. So that was the Drunk Dunk challenge.
Matthias: Drunk Dunk!
Mark: That was insane. We couldn't see a god damned thing.
Mark: And it was a lot of fun.
Mark: Hope you enjoyed it.
Mark: If you want to see more stuff, we made a bunch of stuff on their channel
Mark: And there are old challenges in the past.
Mark: So check the links in the description
Mark: You'll find all of them
Mark: And check out Team Edge's other videos.
Mark: They make TONS of them. Like 3 a week.
Mark: Maybe even 4 a week.
J-Fred: Yeah! You heard!
Matthias: Maybe!
Mark: Maybe!
Mark: I've heard! I heard.
Mark: So thanks again! And as always
Mark: I will see you in the next video.
J-Fred: Peace.
Mark: Buh-bye!
Bryan: Peace!
Bryan: I feel so sick, dude.
Mark: I know, right?
Matthias: Really? I feel great!